[Laughter]
hi I'm Claire and I'm Matt hey I'm Teddy
hey I'm me ray hi I'm joy and I'm Matt
and today we're going to be trying three
different chocolates at three different
price points blindfolded love chocolate
love chocolate yeah chocolate over candy
for sure any day of the week
I feel like chocolate wine and like
yelling at the neighbors perfect night
to what oh this is the first time I've
been blindfolded in front of a camera
el corazon what a song bucket Ellis
HIPAA mummy your trouble how do I know
what I'm reaching for okay I'm touching
[Laughter]
yeah it's like surprisingly heavy can we
yeah okay okay
feels like are we eating mmm this is a
good job is it I like it I like it - I'm
gonna eat more do are you getting that
raspberry flavor at all mm-hmm I'm not
crazy
I love raspberry and chocolate this is
like my favorite one that's caramel it's
like all right it's like Valentine's Day
chocolate it's really sweet
so sweet mmm yeah that is crazy sweet
very good slightly raspberry okay I'm
gonna save some of it so I can taste
later have to guide me okay I'm touching
the next option hmm there's a ball
all right look feels like there are some
drizzles already yeah at this ball let's
eat it Oh mmm mmm Bop tastes like a
Lindor truffle flavor town hmm this just
creamed all over my mouth
like surprise mhmmm here it's a little
smaller almost looks like a mini Twix oh
I know it is this is a twig right away
is it the right twigs or the left twigs
I don't know who invented to it but that
person is the person for me mm-hmm right
oh god damn it it tasted very like
fluffy and that salted caramel like
almost like maybe home maybe tape like
Mooji chocolate as soon as I taste in
this salt from the sea mm-hmm because
any time there's chocolate is always sea
salt yeah very expensive why I think so
too but it was like so like sweet so
there's like too much you think a window
I trap what like what's yours taste like
you does it taste like a Lindor truffle
artistic Karma
like tasted like you know like I'm
trying to say yeah a billionaire
something to like marry me for three
months cheapest with the twigs let me go
middle how's the truffle I think this
one's the raspberry interesting I think
the raspberry is the middle one so most
expensive mid-level cheap I gave the
high five
I had sticky chocolate fingers she is
giving every last card all chocolates
good chocolate give me chocolate
chocolate all day yeah yeah my final
words is you know what bougie chocolate
for yourself and cheap chocolate for the
hoes I can argue with that but all
chocolate is a good charge Oh
[Music]